[Music]
hi and welcome to be someone on the day
of the week week google cloud platform
podcast
i'm john en him here what my colleagues
hey guys do hello john hang en dan
grades of other zo this regard yes is
more emphasis lotion
community  engineer at city technological
and she is working on a party coaches
may before i made nb tiel especially
graphs and then have learned from
physical top kpn hi of interested in
authors
yes db sphinx like i my and then it will
sunbathe baseball
i can handle i can  those stories twitter chips and
pray and had relationship had such
knowledge and then only god that i'm not on
the bar and connex what monovar
grosse pointe crook yes so far can
keep up using games for us these
talents at level d
it cuts and cunning also gives a  russian
the week is my website dan griffiths and
the flesh
social and what's a minus for chipie
but before a death machine for a few
things or bye
[Applause]
ok your energy and the show notes well
when  temple of how to use which may
comments and that it shows mark shaw
black pete bos between body snatchers the
people were hearing permanent of
bottom or risk impairments
led light al so stuff like online tv and
builds violin crowd in which means you can
see phones in  a kind of oil
as soon as this defect iphone and ipod of
research and be able to do deed and one
hundred and ten even so is the
resource screen reader technology that
thing tastes so check out on this show
notes to see my bae bae bae bae bae bae
bae bae bae bae bae  bae bae bae bae bae
bae bae bae bae bae bae bae bae bae bae
bae bae bae bae bae bae bae
bae bae bae bae bae bae bae bae bae
bae bae bae bae bae bae bae bae bae bae
bae bae bae bae bae  bae bae bae bae bae
the chef george and technology to shower
but you samo press and a video
sdc d rings distintas like that we
should be ok too
wired accessible and not just like on
death but  an ever seen that i te  ring
piano for an extreme weather owner
gender is a blog post the
dna research of blog about for steps
to start an the exhibition
with google cloud so you have an iphone
mobile cloud d ok judge los
prevention which you understand and manage
your  center drm pia and be thousand
dollars youtube fine covered information
with credit card snow surinamers and
other person information and this
fashion for scalable and why you share
it in a kind of everything information
guide budgets for its kind notepad it
absolutely the right in compliance
with the  new regulations and keeping
chiara safe and you can then use cloud
city or cloud security comments and there
are absolutely ben manage and store of
this information
so evident shows trail in a keeping
your day
import a huge
credit card numbers already gone
ok taqiyya popeye dan there is a coke
network gattino had weiteres
you singula am cup your doorwa  arder
on behalf of is different is coffee and coke
bootshare interactive table would
n't you your list all results and
humankind scroll through the bush winstons
and and i would be on iphone and sick or coins
and check out would you can the waterline and
everything is if i something  from the boss here
look so weekend may the project becomes
scummy
what your snake eyes i thought this week
and there is no for catherine [ __ ]
arno simpsons tapped out on the chin
station
this is the heavenwood jersey and april 18
wishes or oil
week in it  water down to know exactly
where and sewer run left sale
entropie
other updates two aroma vision out
poor video and ormel intelligence eps or
so in e promovision
age was een danst en er is prima
create your own business training in de
prey emma models on the edge  and now i
have all video huge intelligence
choo choo in the party so
chassis cabin debora mole edge is home
via the tab percentage in sync
video whose customers your
you can say  n picture of in dating and
apps oil is there tyrone
you should be really really cool zo the expo on
dates
be able to detect a jacks en logos
videos and images and allows you to then
try your mother to handle the show it's
perry and chimp jotham
and something you can um I think oh what a beautiful
end who davinci code that direction
panther for
well okay what is there for you so and then
hate and all the powder mixing you will
see another rapping gutter in the week
glasgow
chef with our great friends  who is going to
be
will in the railroad oscars let's go
[Music]
wie hair today havelaar him systolic
community down and semi technologies
enwake war taals wat je expensive and the
watcher company to thank for interaction
so huge of the dutch pie kar the
living in  helsinki
just got community solution engineer at
sammy technological
he image and super the community a
radar open source software reviews
and if it ever the developer and
you experience within the business this
means a guy  fawkes alright documentation
to support pencil developers and the
user's
en de engelsen research and the valley
know new use cases
ar nu applications in the software i
king user experience
yes that will do that with in sandy
dit sounddroid your projects in the uk
mini social music programs  in china
world where i in therapy his death
solution documentation of the awesome
ancelotti
a youtube show there is such a thing as liberal
u in it share like a background in
chicago essence i know how to get into
something piping mini's
jeshua je ex lease targets of the
begining saus  and who was a small
startup joint in the beginning thing and
smelly researching post bilities wooden
images an all scruff more
specifically he was the bridge between
the web designer
so should be in direct contact with potential
users of such an interface and for
developers of its software which  means
that i was not really like this' wie je
wax design but more designing and good
experience for a  nne developers and then
s oh my god no the product could be better
be caught my people on board and wie die
boring this art product
euro is be open source thats called lovie
open source en wie want your images
community around at because i wanted to
spread this  project and also to help
other people and other people to help
als swift developing this awesome people
really enjoy a
inch poor families special in open
source digital out developers you how to
build a span it a show desire and
just give you my people for module
background  and all the phoenix managers
sides gather so clear image
lack empathy
i think sin city games forum
green team who is so far on a social and
you mentally fit regement what
it is wifi j yes sorry via etc never
grave
open source crash again  which enables
you to context list search party om
hier did je putin
more specifically who has instead of a
traditional database where they therein
database has no meaning you do 2
da  tabase that's a know what catalogs
cinder week great mini's mee that
sent your opinion deda you need putin
cheers this already
chose all brands and so and nevels
youtube do
search based on this knowledge within
and to gain more knowledge you can get
more the lesson  had thinks that they hd car
you did there like on the leg there is
now a knowledge graph retain you which
we've
de did of leather it's all from I
have grab my
they are so rhinos such a good offender busy
with eyeliners me  it off to the
babies per se or bet eat is not a
graph db spur cd drive
the structure is based on a graph toe en
lime a big variety of users wimey
multi-user
and query die straf switches die design
graphic u do
epa  which is and who you can already beautiful
views natural language to glory' de
pia matches designed by haer selfs
germany amazing arrive you single by
common extreme sparkle at various the
king james bible and homework lesson
icom the title is not in this goodies
photo  in our managers and mimi
must youtube absolutely model josh so we
can take is an exon poor countries and
cities
so wie her the the country netherlands
warm of with the capitol amsterdam
we have a clear link between amsterdam
and the netherlands pico sam's name is
the capital  pinching
the craft store again so da this is
a link between the netherlands in
amsterdam and I drove and
home spoke shampoo sec and country in the
which is germany
and we have second city in which a girl
in both within with the link gap between
pearl  a which is the capital of
germany
we can automatically classified is and
meet the link to the capital of nowhere
to usb start-ups a 0 what had to billion
euros and things like wish you hot
we did a new in charge john
bradshaw offensive interactions
as  I call you me click in discussion can
it be simple and youth there in your family
the renewed small world mission in their
of something know it seems despair
can see the spread team leader more
info  rmation if yes everything de champs
feyenoord bizarre mary dan
yes that's right zo die is back based on
is opinion set of based on nothing
european a number of fish and relational
traditional database en that is most
importing défense gras en dan passed on
this meaning you  can make now links an
extra real new knowledge and that's
all stars who is the note station c
bridge redesign s classes soliver klaas
country york la city
budget shirt and properties country house
property has capital
and sisters cuba can echo in which
you think not if
yes yes for the graph you do liam in
yes yes for real and reach and graphic
well who wants to make a usable for as
many people as possible so je fork
symbol query language flex
over dvd the dozer hard to the stanton
not really
intuitive if you seen and for the first
time zo madame wit kraft gel is it arch
with how you just a daily base for him
how you something wit d1 it's too i get
back what  you actually you're looking
for
sorry start from these critters en van
der found and some keywords where coming
back all the time
look in my exam both of you know
what you looking for you very often use
the work at so gonna get
discussion fixing the death  by ferry p
function in the rough guide is the get
function en zo je start white get and
then you do you mention the heck
temple of countries
hairdresser als zo what is the most common
use case black for business like that
people use at verdaat
like  na en Tempels camps hakt range and
real-world example that people using les
are for example if you're going on in
this context beast search dan week en nu
kind uur
scientific articles for simple even your
hvd de wezel of articles en je hoorn
look  for specific top i am you white
star blue green with such words which
arnoud xlii present' in this article you
would white star looking for some guys
specific disease but this disease is
takes differently in an article and that
sony find is article and influences have already
dated 1 arno scruff ben you can xlii find
articles nac is so your surge based on set the
context shirts based on exact keywords
ok and that's for most fine by
each morning absorb the grafts that's
everyone's  abide by a user or go or no-go
yes correct and the night's king' is is that
you give and structure 2d that yourself
so manufacturers ontology there is germs
you define your own review but what
happens is a wifi point in detail
factors are generated all  medically 3%
the meaning of these words and that is
not only the planning your own
ontology  also understand it
fit other person nanotechnology
for listen in streaming service and
hardcore definition brother anthologie
via share zo en ontologie is description
of the wadden meanin  g of the word
this time keep us anthologie is be
defined classes and properties
zo is a set early we have uit safe
which can be a country and you describe
what country least
and i country can have properties zo het
cadaver capital the cottage population
might  be insert your region whatever you
wanna give to that end and you can be you
populate
journal grab your database and show you
around country you give
the continents label country
know class true french anal dick
grayson apathy
i am i excel a lot of oil class-c de
jp
sons af countries all in formula 1 so
what say you have property which i guess
what empire
countries for ever be cause that's the
uk house and the great britain and fix
merchant and country
with a side of the country's
herd de  data yes yes sir so who has two
times of properties
klaas can have one is just some day so
if you have the population of a country
it's just a number
outside the exam offset idea gives the
ci  ty is another grader you refer to
this other nood de database and you can
do the same great other countries
you can refer to we are classic and yes
and really like
in just in an anthology that period
was a dud and grab you will enjoy
the  definition
the opinions words and believe that
excuses there so
address jiaxin follower juniperus i a
circle shampoo of light a public big
shampoo and opinions provision
when they that
emilie my mouth you my colleagues
from kind
lodge glasses and evidence fine
quality
something universal fine glycol think  that
archie lardons especially don't argue through
sets or bore a simple
[music]
your this very good example which your
jeans people
begin if anthology in santing ever on the
vines for yourself so in for home
dining bench workshop to the word bank in 5c
bang  you might think about the financial
institution
with another might think of there
riverbank okay so
detail who will be the finder has bank in
ontology and des  cription and that's
where it gets effects representation
which represents something opinion zoey heft
your banks and in a traditional database
share it minus 1 thing that especially roamed
2010 and then another good point is what
she said this that everyone to finance
it differently week in use think  me and
some people my swedish bank with such
people might say so financial
institution zo people don't speak the
same language
so that is why in a long
scruff  have the
other the riverbank ss separating
zo the name is cry just make a difference
between two stewards of so enthusiastic
b-stand manager of tanks and nobody
pedometer of pentecost was so
avene lotion for remembering the things
like it's based on al a c or a  hot
bath someone sherry bodysuit by
improving zo van shampoo hr intern
partners ben mind you some things might
be awesome check sample right person may
be given any other person
eminent giffords terminology put the
madd chadd is in technology and arnhem
fancy well
messenger other get together and
his chip for measuring and testing and
get high fives at my desk
this together corps i become a china
cassidy win super risk is in jack
anthology space  on the edge surroundings
and minbar my and
is wallays double definitions a nice
yes that's correct
and that's what it takes from them their own
ontology and energy bed people
have been trying to make informal
anthology
for [ __ ] simple the web in the bast and
die  biscuits channel agree and informal
en tarjay picasa freeones opinion is
de franky castle
space on their own and fire my bag c
and that's exactly one of the key points
wie when voice-over van can define
their own ontology here zo dik en gry
en als  i de knowledge graph
in their own language and research
willem i de machine learning model
wiebeeld within their knowledge graph to
still be able to meet th  e links between
the thing you mean and the think i'm a
zipper sexy the same but we've just
take the red god without sat silent at adp
conversation japan it had chocolate that is
of power the housing castilleja
bowl and relational database may not  be
but they're looking for all rise like
name and the just keep at home portfolio
for cold had samy
when the father technology of jihad
bridge the get people see that you're
trying to help people s yes so far they fall
turned out the the core  or the arm no scrubs
image then quirinus features or verses
we called cloud product and then who him
for shampoo google
river graders yes those actors and boxes
for anyone can request and they can try
out
previous for some time and who grandis
graders all google cloud
will  and then also ensure your stil
highly developing our software rollout
development by blanco stro google cloud
watches green eyes for some more i set
my youth travis en so nice wie kan met
a new and updated version to get u  p
travels to start a test with chicago
power and google cloud something like that defies I
read there
and if the leak bronze test about der and
chassis then like and all three that half past
five in the hall
development exactly this help other
machine learning couple of course
directly so  for something like that you
mention
3 the muse just machine learning dat and
his wife there was something tanks en aan ml
ml engine and other stages
addresses times essential gianni in the
fortress prefer to think of alcohol
cadel machinery rather
well in an edition like it's not  only
google cloud witjes helping as a
separate as a google and jane euro picas
beer silent in the start-up face of a of the
business and google really helpful
still shampoo time to go when the
en met de ladder people there and was
streaming see tickets  and also it seems
the podcast read more organizing touch so
this she will profile that people have not
died site ever imagine that their
power bits and bytes in faro salon 10 hours
long  passage keep it jc google glass
half an hour specific liander premium
account support that every can see
that name is a message that confused and then
that mimi it is on an absurd
double on the reef crime
chinchero
my child stabbed him what is you coaching with
a fiction me that direction and who knows
sure that were clear that they
choir developers any more info get stuck
is that who had such community backups
griot regal
so although they might not be done right
relations
the networking grieve
windows faxes and  that she curiosity that
your startup is open source belgian hard
further els
zo de you ever created a like
sas product to license andorra has a
managed online cheap to manage that ferry
yes then the you this can it works your ear
i blog knightley
you not  stolen jeroen koster and
reading light of how does it work
yes it is so trivial is in the open source
and sometimes
put open source outside what more is
doing sammy technology that about
consulting help for getting started with
building will give you for companies and
secondly because we've shared is open
source it comes wit and open source
license
and for bigger business is 3 over budget
enterprise
which comes with the liability me co2
was found at like more  building the
business and that whiskey as a mi no pay
are now still a simple texas essor
prominent beer in an open source a
king and a chica a machine
success something like that critics that bizarre can your
inbox open source is ice or something like that  n
barbarians and support for in a few
hours there is in the green room and i a
long battle scenario
even look at me your popular applications
of close race like uber and netflix i
play then maybe one hanger product
of which google bic table
my  sql though that sound service is
neglected and audio en they open source
for this together in this list to catch
the barking how it cross again and
that is why i wanna [ __ ] you much to
remain advise  urs die the set something
very interesting that be and quiver
space where disagree
coutinho charger for you in a house
lotion what is communion mix for
specific dimention your never in
detail
all that sort of thing potential never
gruber
in on something on some features  in your
run production for your single or use
cases for mini third point between
bilities picasso of all teams who about
judge her machine
so is jess vacation so week and fork is
simple in the aérien
cybersecurity
is classifying emails ideas carp tent
shot restaurant agree  fishing
or not based on the context of de e-mail
en de necessary which is already in your car
and secondly
is an enterprise you can gain knowledge
parents die en thea that you already have
so i have lot of customer details
eccelpoel
de knowledge graph may  be able to make
new links point five teams of god
about and a leica her memetic
new business case gras so
the maybe home aspects li  miet is
absolutely true the for more words
grimaud die identifying the frame en
new on youtube is a suspects such a
winsum science channel to customers in
more area business and a' and b' there an
old religions
or other companies it seems like to be
and acting use your phone o allah berg
yes and she is called wifi and that stop already
because of this app die epa level zo
beone en depicting santing nice your
application on top of that it's just jpl
level so people can build your own
interfaces your product  or whatever
zal geek and connects keeps in
however they want you people the re-10 the
cpb sandeep creator operations and tapping
works trade the work on a prospective
of grandpa experience all night i cry carve
goodbye and epa and rhino laikipia reese
has this the hard committee p&b dan helps
much you will and johanna en wat helps
developers beyond hier dokumentation run
to link to happen workplace
who you know so documentation easy
prating and also really big thing to
work ee  n bucket cm karlie riding it
outside okay accommodation wiha loss
enters for examples with your critics
tryout in your own review the monastery
if you sign up for one en ar website and
then you hear mix the eps straight for
this beware or something  how you have the epa is
a leftover you live
and if you wanna populate as much the
database you use restful
e-bike as so
laser listed on our website and explains
how you can do cities and up-date isam doen
and if you wanna three de  share so other
guests on 10 hours
specific looking for or explore the da
be cause you're looking for something
you don't know about door looking for
new
relations and you're doing this already via
the graph caleb uw met je is designed
from  million perspective so is based on
natural language ending like this is of
course also document it magic samples
hd video or crash us the developers chance
yes i mention that you do ladder open
source community they can not apps can
francis probably
stalker full of flavor  with whom you die oil
winter price of what is channel to
help them active de goals
coat over and sprays switcher you big
business is we have it solution engineer
and the solution engineer can help you
for me start zo thick and help you
refining use cases  and then building and
ontology together pike's sl sir john
menschen team have what you guys from
begining
really help what's it called en dan already
setting up the whole and fire my track
in pro flight help that and if they
have any questions they can always come
back to the solution engineer zo right
now with real
flexible oh yes no thats why you working
in terms of use this in desen dach des
indes god who you flexible in contact
for is our customers
the symbol for so that is good
and now is and de  praise your channel jury leon
one solution engineer must she's always
available free je
yes there are not in the minister that
name and those of course people four
weddings and possible you might become
baby in the feat  ure evolving in
convention is do you want a limit
apps harder then you already have my
content if you don't loose
it went another lecture there new website
wit now dokumentation pikachu sorry liz
and new version of rivia this self this
zombie  diaries this podcast oil online
by the end of october reboot
make-up care and iced in amsterdam new
york and san francisco
de this arnoud set yet but we can
communicate is via a newsletter
sarah website
als there n role as op gaster always at this
rate  for is absolutely something with a
pee revenue guardsman amazing company
dress with show you the now gimme gimme there
a cup of coffee without
yes and davy jones said that seems like a lot
but also work grange isn't it eefje
culturel single driver rather in
helsinki
it is before ten in  business class
obtained i must join as a kits for
joining was a template and and thank you
gary for joy is for and kneel to
see the great in such a thing can so c
members or and continuous  hearts
tanks forum feeding thank you all for
talking two hot wheels and all grazie
that was winnings iphone
yes i was pretty amazing en music and
language of the seb sorry intercédé ontology
and how it swing use the button a'
person is ryan site for very cool  and the
foil and that taking a beep beep
what they're doing for awesome der links
to the show notes for you to see there
were vicarage and c bit more certain
product so
gapless children crash of the week
so maybe some kind of machine shop which
is one  world
high touch you reach and the five and what
is a minus for jeep gary
or incorrect in ca cell phone likessee
all
this had frites 3pt library sardi earl
gray tea tour camp iphone 3 iphone 6
all engine power view point and
shoot day do than 10  o'clock the official
police and the fly vs jerk first choice i
try to say it's time to look at your
coach here do juni fingers pipe and
tube and drove and me a salad 10 change
and eyes people boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh  boy oh boy oh nice well and then the city
that is it an ant another support
might and see in the more so yes
sickly on the chrysler is keep calm
and see what you using
say you can operate across him en dat
jim en shirley de  door closed the
countdown clock for all others on this
website are found
she can then clock so sweet on your channel
my de en or office ebony is so
typical british
it stall clare sickly the dt&v
words and walked to marx and
disco balls gonna shop in the show
notes and maybe someone who really bravo
like
designs and external icon donk look like
a day heaven earth and than people in a
working with iphone sprite and
journal to be able to you know monetary
chinese the club hits
12 for new use the right on the  beach
police can families for an
employment agency
scanning mind who the glamor
of the clock tower in the change and like
any body wash sorry the ball the met now
work will take all other millenial bar
p&a double ap ril change and waikiki
your channel like that i am gary and be in
the upcoming my neck sea kayak slim from
the belgian [ __ ] you up and on the link in
the show notes
nice and check out like a new to
me
my run brothers mare de anyway  m
going to be the best with your i'm super
excited and other side
and neat can white rush arne bye
friends and family cino celebrate this
moment on sunday person on a
love on youtube can in november sophie
van abb
richardus dabei an icon orange
workshop  my open match smatch
matchmaking frameworks of friese stabij
i wanna get int estate an open source
project for games in je nou an actemium
a spreadsheet cool and this local add
them to your home care gain something
pleasure
and who wins some sinus pi listening
and we'  ll see all night sleep see your neck
definitely had such a
[Music]
home